since woo had everyone in Hollywood
scratching their heads today with some
not-safe-for-work tweet seemingly about
her own show let's break it all down it
all started with a cryptic tweet she
sent following news that her ABC series
fresh-off-the-boat had been renewed for
a sixth season around the same time she
tweeted so upset right now that I'm
literally crying ah
she followed up with another X would
have simply F in hell there you have it
she also replied to a fan when some
people started thinking is this about
the show being renewed this seemingly
put it up at first a fan said Congrats
on your renewal great news too as she
responded no it's not now important to
know that tweet right there from
Constance has since been deleted but it
she also took it to Instagram because on
the fresh-off-the-boat Instagram page
vase were celebrating the season 6 who
knew all if you look down there
Constance commented dislike she hop back
on Twitter this time to defend herself
writing that was not a rampage it was
just how I normally talk I say F a lot I
love the word y'all are making a lot of
assumptions about what I was saying and
know it's not what it's about no it's
not what this is all about stop assuming
she says so she seemingly backtracked
but also doubled down because here's the
latest tweet from her today she says
today's tweets were on the heels of a
rough day and were ill-timed with the
news of the show please know I'm so
grateful for fot B renewal I love the
cast and crew I'm proud to be a part of
it for all the fan support thank you and
for all who support my casual use of the
word f thank you too I mean this is
pretty shocking guys but you know what
Constance is on a bit of a streak though
you know fresh off the success of crazy
rich Asians and then she's next going to
be seen in hustlers opposite JLo is she
ready to say goodbye to fresh off the
boat she says she's not
[Music]
[Applause]
you